كل حال بعيدا عن المشاعر سنتحدث علميا هذه
المره بين الفرق الكبير بين الرجال
والنساء في عالم الفضاء قد تكمل الاجابه
في القدره على تحمل مستويات عاليه من
الاشعاع في الفضاء بحسب ناسا فان النساء
تتاثرن باكثر من ضعف خطر الاصابه بالسرطان
الرئه مقارنه بالرجال عند تعرضهن للاشاعه
لنفس الفتره ووفقا لتقرير مشهور على موقع
لايف ساينس فان حدود حمايه رواد الفضاء من
خطر الاشاعه وضعت عام
1989 وهي تختلف تباعا حسب العمر والجنس
وعلى عكس ما يعتقد الكثيرون فان الاكبر
سنا هو صاحب الحظ الاوفر للبقاء فتره اطول
في الفضاء ويترك لفتره اطول للتعرض للاشعه
السبب ان ما بقي من حياته اقل من رائد
الفضاء الشاب ومع ذلك في عام 2021 طالبه
وكاله ناسا بتغيير حد الاشعاع الوظيفي الى
600 ميليفر لجميع رواد الفضاء على النساء
الاصغر سنا كم متوسط لدرجه الخطر